[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
risque elle a 18 ans et l'ont suivi je
suis rentrée au théâtre avec ma paire de
christian dior darfour là ça sentait
mauvais qu'on me prenne moudre la chasse
à la laguna et marc est beau c'est ma
mort je sais rien
je suis millionnaire je connais bien
mais je vais faire jouer ma cellule a
forci faire des va-et-vient deuxième
division de graffitis ce ne sont pas les
reins pour de monsieur normand damien
saint trond vie des prisons problème
personne va me coucher en issus des
zones urbaines les amis sont devenus les
ennemis restent vrais même s'ils ont des
pluies font trop il est prêt mais plus
de jeux sur ne permet plus que je suis
danse et l'ol a du jus dance est
entraîneur on a fait rentrer à laâyoune
je suis libéré des funérailles aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe
jb rap est vulnérable à zhuhai où je
suis un bon coup bas et à lille ça sent
l'ail le jouer à une veillée du souvenir
à gauche depuis des mois
je suis le cauchemar de dark vador puis
passent des journées comme à slash dans
un bac de riga ça y est j'ai mon super g
avec mon sac du riz marseillais j'm'en
malgré la traque second tour des
flandres à cause des traces aux agences
d'exactions menotté cérémonie fera ce
site a vu le feu à vue je n'ai pas dans
les adultes en garde à vue sur nous
tous les ressources et pierre laffitte
jaloux guinée ont joué par billy jean
plus de jeux sur lyon mais plus que je
suis aux joies du jus dance et noël à
dijon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
le mans
la roja 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]